I start the video.
Um,
tell me what's up for folks who would just hit me on Ustream.
You can just start talking about Sam Harris.
A big,
big fight.
Islamophobia.
Okay,
well good experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
What are those guys?
What does that neighborhood like now discuss?
Is this you right here on the right.
That's me all the way over there.
But scan my legs disgusting.
And what were
his legs?
Which one of his legs?
That right there.
The Italians moved down to Charlotte.
Had money.
Guys are the union.
I'm Yulia Jorma teams and make $24 an hour.
What?
I make up about 80 grand,
they go to Atlantic city.
I don't want that much.
I'm saying they all moved down the shore and the rest is fucking like not even
killed but I'm Puerto Rican.
It's like El Salvadorian Hindus.
That's how it always goes.
It comes in waves.
Fucking crazy.
And then my grandparents,
it was all time and then it changed to black and then it went from black and
Puerto Rican and they went in from Puerto Rican,
Dominican,
Nicaragua and shit like that.
Delicious.
I'm on site twice the size.
It's giant.
Huge.
Almost too huge.
I thought it was almost to the month,
but then,
uh,
when I first got it,
I took it to England and that was on the phone a lot,
like doing text messages and emails and stuff.
And I was like,
this is a much better experience for that much better.
I don't know how to shut it off.
So if everything,
so you were just a here just with a hearing and Henner in Manchester,
right?
Yeah.
That was this guy's,
yeah.
Well I train with here on,
I know and Oh,
you training with him now you would train Chris Harder,
is that who you're talking to?
And I was training with him and I'm a black belt under here and in Henner and
then I kind of migrated to hearing you the bad ass of the intellectuals.
Now when you go look the skeptic conferences,
they have seminars.
Uh,
I,
I don't,
I don't think I've been to a skeptic's conference since I started,
well,
I shouldn't say Steph skeptic conference,
I should say debate.
You know,
you've,
you've been in quite a few very entertaining debates online,
um,
more atheist than skeptic,
right.
With the,
I,
there was one that you did with this really smart dude.
It was really fascinating.
Um,
I believe he was a Jewish guy and he was so passionate about,
about religion.
He was so passionate about the intellectual pursuit of religion and it was
really fascinating to watch him like we've,
his dance,
like he tried to make it seem like it made sense.
It clearly didn't,
but it was fascinating to watch him.
We've this dance and it was all pros and delivery and drama and you put it
together in such an entertaining for,
you almost want to go with them.
Like God,
maybe.
Maybe there is a god.
Maybe the Bible's true.
I think you're talking about a rabbi Wolpe yes,
that's exactly what I'm talking about.
Debate at twice,
once alone,
and once with Hitchins and it was Hitchins and I against role hoping in another
rabbi.
You get accused of something that I think is very fascinating.
You get accused of Islamophobia and it's by liberals and progressives.
There's this new thing that's really interesting to me that you can goof on
Christianity to the fucking cows come home,
you can shit on Mormonism and polygamy and any other cult Scientology.
You can goof on anything and no one says a peep.
But if you say anything about Islam,
progressive people will dean you Islamophobic and they'll say there's something
wrong with you.
I think that's a really interesting thing that we do.
And I show there's a lot of psychological reasons because you know we're,
we're bombing them because here there's less bendy right here and going back to
this and you've gotta I handle,
don't put your hand around.
Put It on this.
Okay.
And if you're going to put your hand around,
go like this and squeeze the fingers together.
You like that?
Oh,
not the small finger right here.
Yeah,
now it's squeezed them.
Okay,
now you're cutting the blood spy off the thumb a little bit.
A little bit.
Okay.
This is a curl.
This is a rip curl and rip curl and rip.
And you get used to that.
And when you're cranking guy's neck or choking him,
it doesn't slip.
If you squeeze the thumb and also you know,
you,
you're going like this and it might slip off.
Right.
But it's my slip.
Yeah,
but no,
not that finger.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now Curl and Rep.
So you feel like this is more stable than I do of all.
Uh,
but uh,
I always see this this way.
Now you're going like this,
you're using your back to c and you're pulling them in clothes.
It doesn't feel like you smash your fingers.
Like this is the time.
But just,
just the thumb.
Squeeze the thumb.
Are you squeezing the thumb,
your theater,
getting red.
Now as you squeeze the thumb and go like this,
that's a curl.
And this is a rep across his face.
I like that.
Huh?
Now do it the other side.
Yeah.
And go this way.
Now you're still working out at the Machados or any of that.
Yeah.
And then he brought was to everybody.
I've been injured for a little bit about how big of a neck injury and it just
got of time go car said to come by our place of not to prove yourself,
you know,
just to go there and see the place I used to have those days.
They are,
these are uh,
peer counseling.
Um,
I like to use these for the hook because even for,
for kids,
I had also it teaches the,
um,
it just,
it,
it simulates a lot better cause I feel the pad when you're hitting something,
I'm holding the myths,
but they can actually see the power in this one.
So when I teach it,
I teach you like the karate kid hook.
Even all my students do this.
So you didn't,
you know the credit kid when he has a on the bow and the,
he was in the island and the guy was,
he had the drum thing,
right.
And everybody was doing it right.
So it's kind of like that because you're spinning your hip and your whole hook
comes from your hip and your arm is just a rope in your hand as a rock.
So I tell people,
visualize your hand being a rock.
I mean,
and you're harming a rope,
no power in your arm.
Your arm is relaxed,
your hand is tight,
and it all starts from your hip.
So just so just turns that way and you spin it and you don't stop.
You go in this direction has almost the same with the right hook,
but it's mainly the left took,
I teach that way.
So it's like a whip,
it's like a whip,
but you're hitting them with a rock and most efficient use of movements.
And then,
and then the commitment is not there.
Like with a right hand,
if I throw it hard,
I'm giving the person my hip so the wrestler could get my hip.
When I'm throwing my hook,
I'm trying my hip over there on the way past,
I'm trying to hit their chin from my hip's going here.
So even if it's a wrestler,
I just step out this way.
It's easier to defend a take down cause I'll commit all the way.
Even taking my eyes off him cause it's really hard to counter this hook.
He might grab her single and I can step through,
but I want all my coat hook.
So when I'm did hooks I did it this way.
And then,
and when I,
when I teach them not coming back first,
the way I teach them to not pull back first is have this guy tried to drop it
because you'll see a guy like this and then they pulled back to,
so the hook every time.
But if you're out here more like I used to have chuck find out here.
So then from here it says he steps in,
you can just turn it right over.
So if he's right here,
you don't pull it back first.
He can drill that.
Alright.
And so it's ascending,
it's going to get a network connection with other second.
Okay,
great.
So this is easy.
Um,
yeah android APP is much nicer than the iPhone is it?
Yeah.
Cause at first it was really annoying.
So that's gone.
So now if you go into your piggy bank,
okay,
wait a bit.
That's all right.
Don't phone.
So I go send.
That's all.
I liked the Samsung.
Thank you.
This is cool.
Now I can say,
so I say scan the Qr code this most you heard that the um,
the mega is not as good as the galaxy.
You know that resolution is not as good.
It's actually the guts of the gs three,
a galaxy
guts.
It's not that good.
It's just big.
But I gotta copy George Dress.
You see how it says one,
three HC.
It's just to send me this in an easy way.
You could also copy paste that in an email.
There's nothing secret about this.
It's like an email address.
Just your identifier.
And at one point I say 0.005
and said,
and asked me for a second password because I'm trying to send money
and then you just wait a few seconds.
It's still sending on this side.
Oh,
thank you.
Okay.
Now this was not from my phone to your phone.
This was from me to the bitcoin network.
From the Big Horn network to your phone.
So if you weren't,
Kuala Lumpur would have taken the same amount of time.
Right?
Let's just mediated by the network.
Now tell me when you could send $5 electronically to some random person without
jumping through hoops and taking seven days.
And I know this is a lot more than paypal obviously,
but even as,
as to how it does such a better job.
And if I wanted to,
I want them to freeze this by the way.
No one,
oh no,
this is sitting on keys or a wallet on this phone.
Also on the website to best as a backup.
Now,
if somebody wanted to buy more bitcoin,
how would they go about doing that?
Um,
two ways for Americans.
Probably the easiest one is you go to coinbase.com I can write it down for you.
So Coinbase is a San Francisco company.
They work with the banks,
they're registered as a money transmission.
They've done some of the regulation.
So connect via ACH,
direct debit to your bank account.
They'll do two small deposits to verify that it's yours and you give them,
you know,
like paperworks.
And then once they've got that link up,
you say,
buy bitcoin $5,000 boom.
It's going to say,
this is the price we're going to get you.
It's going to debit your account in four days and four days later your account
debits the dollar accounts,
and it's a bit coin appears in your bitcoin account and the long time it takes
just because the dollar side is slow.
Then once you have it in Bitcoin,
you can send it to anywhere for 40 cents.
It's the standard say by,
it's great meeting you.
Thank you so much.
Can't wait to talk to you again.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.